so we bring you another installment in
our ongoing story about California and
its long descent from a middle-class
utopia an inspiration to the rest of the
world to the kind of place that Donald
Trump wouldn't want immigration from for
example third-world countries are known
for election fraud California's DMV has
just admitted to accidentally
registering more than a thousand 1500
non-citizens to vote
Los Angeles meanwhile is grappling with
an epidemic of typhus in this country
typhus in San Francisco an app called
snap crap disgusting the treu has just
launched to help residents their report
local waste on the sidewalk to the
government Victor Davis Hanson is like
me a native California he's a senior
fellow at the Hoover Institution he's
family's been there for six generations
in the same house he joins us tonight
picture of his Hanson is an honor to
have you on the set thank you after all
these years were talking to you by
remote so I just let's just stand back
really quickly and ask the obvious
question how did the greatest state go
to what it is now you know it was a
perfect storm Tucker
first of all we had three trillion
dollars come in for capitalization of
Facebook Google and Apple and it
convinced millions of people in that
area where the money was concentrated
Hollywood the big universities along
that coast that they were not subject to
the ramifications of their own ideology
so they could afford to dream and in and
have all of these restrictions greater
regulations green utopian ideas and it
was always going to affect other people
mostly in the interior but not always so
housing went up because of the
regulations small businesses fled taxes
we had the highest basket of gasoline
sales and income taxes and in the nine
state doesn't make sense I mean the the
taxes in Saudi Arabia are very low
because they have like the Bay Area this
like there were other elements to this
disaster unfortunate we had about 10 to
15 million people who came across the
southern border yes out legality without
English without a high school diploma
and not on a Mara Craddock basis so all
of a sudden California became a medieval
Society it's like a keep the coastal
strip is the castle keep were the elite
live and everybody else serves
the middle-class is fled and we have one
third of all welfare recipients the
United States 20% of the state lives
below the poverty line yet we have the
most billionaires so it's a pre-modern
and it's a postmodern society when you
pay taxes and you get schools that are
46 in the nation and infrastructure that
Forbes rated 49 thank God for mrs. so
the rest of the Arkansas I used to say
that now it's California so the rest of
us and our viewers who don't live in
California must be thinking okay but
what does have to do with us should we
be worried about this in the rest I
think so because California gave us some
Asian Reagan Pete Wilson and it was
sudden it flipped suddenly to a
one-party state and that was this weird
new combination of the Democratic Party
it's a pyramidal Society were very
wealthy America's wealthy people are
left-wing now they're very ultra wealthy
yes and then they have a subsidized poor
on the on the bottom and that was the
paradigm that over-regulated overtaxed
and sent people out of question I
honestly don't understand so let's say
you're the forty one-year-old multi
billionaire who owns Twitter yeah and
ten minutes away people are dying of
Odie's in the sidewalk why don't you do
something I mean Kearney you feel guilty
about your wealth so in the abstract you
can afford to be left wing and help the
quote poor while your kids go to in the
mineral park Sacred Heart or castilleja
yeah or and then you have a big walls
which again remember walls don't work on
the southern border but they sure work
in Atherton and Hillsboro around your
estate yes so you have ways with your
power wealth and influence and navigate
around the ramifications of your own
ideology and that's what they do but I
think they would want to help the people
right outside their door you think so
you go to Redwood City which is the
service area for Silicon Valley and poor
Mexican American people are living six
and seven families to a house right
under the noses of these people so I
don't think they're very liberal at all
no they're not they're they're not
liberal at all no and they've ruined the
state it's so depressing I'm so glad
that you're here with us I'm glad to be
here you're our viewers love you so
thank you for coming thank you for
having me